so did Peter a film about doppelgangers
how did you access your your darker side
in this inner second person well first
of all I think a film is great
permission to do that you know it was a
requirement that I go there and it's
it's really about befriending the
darkness in all of us you know and being
patient enough to coax it out to make
use of it
I think good in society we often just
suppress that side it's unacceptable you
know we we ignore it and that's how it
ends up growing an ugly head and
becoming destruction that we see in the
world is it kind of like a dark side to
maybe that American dream of the
all-american family going on a holiday
and having a great time
yeah I mean you know for the great
privilege comes great cost you know and
I think that's what this film is
exploring it's in some on some levels
that in order to have that cellphone you
know there's certain people who are
compromised you know and yeah being
aware of that duality in life that is
very much a part of the human experience
how did you access that voice that was
amazing I'm guessing it was you and not
do you know effects no it was me and it
was inspired by spasmodic dysphonia
which is a condition that is brought
about by oftentimes by trauma sometimes
emotional sometimes physical sometimes
just inexplicable where the vocal folds
begin to spasm involuntarily creating
this irregular flow of air and yeah
creating the kind of jagged speaking
voice and I I was inspired by that and
then built from there the script had
mentioned that she had she had not
spoken for a long time so I was creative
licensed to do that and it was really it
was a it was so much fun to have that
kind of creative task you know and I
worked with my ent and a vocal therapist
and a and an absent coach all at once to
make sure that I could do
it's a flea when it was powerful thank
tell me about working with Jordan Peele
is your director Oh Jordan he's amazing
and it had been a dream of a very short
dream but from watching get out to work
with him as a director and my dream came
true way cooler than I could have
expected it to and he is just such a
compassionate gentle intelligent and yet
egoless artist you know and he was very
collaborative from the very start once
he'd given me the role he spoke to me as
though I was the expert on the people
that he had created you know and to hear
him ask questions of me way before I was
even ready to answer them but with full
confidence that I would come to to to be
the authority on these two women was
just so encouraging and you know that
kind of projection of of trust and
respect only breeds trust and respect
and creativity so I really feel like I
grew exponentially as an artist because
of his directing we've already seen you
in so many different roles in your
career so far was a game-changer in 2013
when you got that Oscar did you suddenly
go off with completely different roles
well that film 12 years estate was my
first film so my career has been built
off of that what a start and well it's
fantastic seeing Eunice and how
different to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe you were part of with Winston
before right yeah this is a different
world a very different world much darker
world and it was fun to be able to go
from that to from background that to
this with Winston because we have a long
history as friends we went to drama
school together so we speak the same
creative language and we have a trust
for each other in each other as friends
as well as artists
we could really support the bold choices
each one of us was making and be there
for each other and it was nice to have
that comfort you know being in Jordan
peels sophomore film is is no small
thing you know it's a lot of pressure
and he was able to ease that for me just
by being a familiar face and and such a
passionate support system